your fine girl really girl your whole
career is [ __ ] blown up you got a
real career now man you go out there you
sell tickets
you're not playing bananas in New Jersey
to ten people like me
oh they yeah well I'm went over there
and played a by the railroad tracks yeah
it was a fire on a train while I was
onstage believe you man half the people
what's it like now where you go to a
place in the tickets are sold it's got
to be a great feeling at this point
right yeah I guess it I mean it
definitely is it is different you know
it's funny it's like you can't you
almost forget what it was like when it
wasn't interesting and you felt and you
just almost forget about it quick and
you also get nervous that like you know
I feel more pressure now to make jokes
right whereas before I just felt a
pressure to be myself right but now it's
like they want to be funny they paid
good money to see you right and now I
feel a little bit of that all the time
as some of it I don't like and some hope
I'm trying to find ways in my own like
to get back into a place where I just
feel like that pressure isn't there well
you won't even in like a day even in
like a day-to-day basis you know like I
mean Nick's done so much to help our
podcast grow and like Instagram and
write you know he really championed a
lot of different ideas and you know so
it's been everything you guys got is
professional art of like the cameras you
know the content it's all like it's like
podcasting is a business now it's almost
like for our friends who don't have
podcasts like and who still think like
doing a late-night set matters it's like
your best shoot is so 20 you're out of
your man it's 2019 yeah the only way to
get ahead is to do like you know having
somebody out here like like the Joe
Rogan like you know all you guys you
know get like that's like being on The
Tonight Show like you guys so like you
know Johnny Carson was like the guy and
then like all the comedian's we've ever
heard of Seinfeld Ray Romano all these
guys who blew up and became icons did so
through Carson and now I feel like it's
Joe Rogan it's like now you got you know
you Bert Kreischer Tom Segura all these
guys are selling more tickets than
anybody what's the common theme well you
know you guys all you know crushed it
when you came on Rogan you're all
crushed it and then cuz there's one
thing it's like people comedians could
go on big podcasts and not do well and
then nothing happens so it's like one of
those things you guys were all you guys
were all great
then you guys all went on the episodes
and crush so it's like now his fans
become your fans but now it's not even
now it's your fans so now it's like when
you go yeah maybe the first time they
heard of you was through this guy or
through that everybody needs a godfather
yeah you know but that now it's like yo
you've converted real fans and I think
the only way that we can do that now in
2019 is through podcasting so when I
came out here to promote my special I
was like man I want to do Bert and I
want to do Theo I would love to have
done Rogan and but it's not possible
right now I get I gotta get to the next
level but but I was like that's more
important to me than doing any
late-night [ __ ] like the late-night book
is like oh you know cuz it's it's so PC
now they're like oh I had jokes about my
daughter
yeah Porto Rican and you know and they
were all my Comedy Central special
because one thing I'll say about Comedy
Central is they're about the comedian
first that's why it's dope that's why I
like specials that come out on Comedy
Central are dope because they they that
the executives there are not scared
they're like you know this is the name
Comedy is in our network right now if
you think that shit's funny even if it's
crossing the line and whatever then
we'll stand by you and protect you so
it's not something Ron Funches clips and
he's just did really well and I she's
only just clips huh yeah where he called
his son the n-word yeah yeah man
and I respected it was just like that's
hot it was so funny yeah dude but for
them to be willing to also put that down
and I just saw one of yours too much
they started putting clips here there's
no clips of mine up now yeah someone yes
so I have a clip actually one of the
clips I put up is me impersonating my
poor my daughter can we play it or not
yeah sure I don't care will we get in
trouble for playing that name well it's
where is it posted it's on my Instagram
okay yeah fine in his daughters Puerto
Rican yeah my Puerto Rico well actually
this the the clip that I was on my
answer I'm I'm gonna post a darker one
tomorrow the clip that's on my bill that
crib you know what I'm saying yeah baby
they they they they said I couldn't do
it on late-night or I could do those
jokes but I couldn't impersonate and put
on a Puerto Rican accent cuz I'm not
Puerto Rican and it's like that's such
[ __ ] like it's my daughter
yeah you know what I mean it's my kid
it's your kid and you know what's funny
is they'll let anybody get on there and
impersonate like somebody from the south
or some Midwest yeah or somebody who
they think is you don't know uneducated
as long as the only educated person
isn't black it's but if it's like
they're white in a majority then it's
fine
but the thing is the people then on all
these networks they're [ __ ] white
yeah but that's why I like what you have
like the six the type of success you
have and the the way that you're selling
tickets now is so powerful because you
could not that you're a scandalous dude
unless do still finger women do you
still get paid to finger women well
that's not anymore okay so you sure
you're not scandalous dude and it's like
even if even if you said something that
was out of bounds unintentionally your
fans are still gonna be there man you're
still gonna go to wherever a place and
sellout that theater where some of these
dudes aren't comedian friends who are
tied up with these on these networks
like they say one [ __ ] their [ __ ]
career is done you know everything will
be taken away from them but you got real
fans that [ __ ] with you you could say
whatever you want to them because
they're like and that's what I want
that's what you guys have okay and
that's what I'm going after like I got a
podcast called the history hyenas yeah
it's you and Gianna's mananas Papas and
we go [ __ ] wild in that podcast and
he's uh where's he from he's Greek isn't
he's Greek yeah we go wild and our fans
you know they're not as powerful and big
as your guys fan base is yet but it's
like you know we're trying to get there
man we just with it's unfiltered [ __ ]
we're talking about history but we're
being honest about [ __ ] you know you
know it's dumb certainly deserve a man
you and Andrew Schultz or two like the
funniest guys that always think about
the schultzy is his Schultz he's got a
career that's that like you man Schultz
Schultz whoever he goes he sells out and
he put his [ __ ] on every Network cenotes
shelter everybody everybody's sonoda is
our special every single he was a like a
mail Shelley I heard all kinds whatever
[ __ ] they said but he was the the
best comedian I saw when I was in new
yeah now he's got millions and millions
and millions of views and what does that
translate to ticket sales yeah so it's
like you know you gotta have this
mindset where it's like the fit we got
the fans give us power like we and we
have the fans have direct access to us
and we have direct access to them it
wasn't like that in the 90s it's like
you know I mean like Jerry's Jerry
Seinfeld can only be Seinfeld with one
show on NBC you know and there was only
one big show there was a few networks
it's like now with this oversaturation
it's like man you like some you could
walk you could be set you could walk
past the theater that you have sold out
and people may not even recognize you
because they're sold out with your
specific fans whereas like back in the
day it's like to be like a big you know
if a guy who was selling out theater
tickets he would not be able to get
through the airport without having to
take a thousand autographs right but
shit's different now like John Wayne
yeah man it's like who else jumped
[ __ ] Marilyn Monroe
No Kareem abdul-jabbar Korean I'm
telling to entertainer there may be new
John Newton that's something you know
John Newton I mean I feel so great
fathering you know how I happened in the
like you know I mean I know I did a lot
of work over the years doing stand-up
but you did your thing man you just you
know and now and now look and it's a
beautiful thing because now it's like
you have an opportunity to like be out
here for like long format stuff people
get to know you that feel like they're a
part of your family
yeah and then they come out to the shows
man and you'll never lose them you'll
never lose the fans you tell people like
you won that I think are fun dude you
could do something [ __ ] up tomorrow
and maybe I'll lose ads on the podcast
yeah but you ain't gonna you weren't
gonna lose your fans what do you think I
would do they'd be [ __ ] up an honest
crime you could see me doing a medic
that honest real [ __ ] that I could see
you doing a real crime and I'm gonna
tell you a couple about you yeah okay so
like a guy like you well first of all
you look like you're on crystal meth
like you know what I mean like I know
you're not but like you look like like
like it would be it would be shocking to
me that a guy that looks like you isn't
using crystal meth like I'd be it I'm in
shock that you're not why cuz there's
not a t-shirt under the sweater what
this is just a sweater to skin sweater
to skin yeah and really like and just
like the hair and the beard it's like
it's like you just look like on a beard
well whatever like it's got like a civil
war head you know what I mean and it
just looks like like you use drugs to
like get through your pain you know I
mean so I would think so I so definitely
like robbing a liquor store is what you
look you have that robbing a liquor
store look you also look like you could
be like you're you a suspect in any
making a murderer [ __ ] like you're on
the list for sure you're on the short
list wow you know what's crazy as my
sister can't even read but what does it
have to do with us right now hope you
enjoyed that video and you can watch
another and you can watch this one you
can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one